hello everyone and welcome to a very
short video where i want to address
something that a lot of you have been
commenting on in the previous
few videos regarding the official random
championship that
that has taken place online now but it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the official random
format of chess it mostly has to do with
online chess
and mouse slips in particular so there
was the game
uh car carwana versus kasparov where
kasparov lost
a game uh in a better position due to a
mouse sleep and also peter wheeler lost
a game to magnus carlsen
in a slightly worse but probably
manageable position
also due to a mouse slip and a lot of
you said that uh this should be fixed
somehow we should
address this issue somehow they should
have uh
prepared some sort of a mechanism that
will you know
uh pop up when someone does a mouse slip
uh whenever there's an obvious mouse
slip but the reason
why i don't think such a thing is
possible is that there is no way to know
if a mouse slip is
actually obvious and i don't think
there's a way of addressing this
issue at all i mean uh unless we like
have some sort of a neural interface
i i don't think we'll ever be able to
tell if a mouse slip
was actually obvious and this is one one
game that i decided to show we've
already covered this game so i'm not
going to show you the game
uh if you haven't seen it it's a game
119 versus magnus carlsen from the 2019
world rapid championship
uh where it was a pretty intense game uh
magnus was better than 11
bounced back and then in the end
something terrible happened for levin
and this is the position from the game
uh so and this is an over the board game
of course not an online game in 2019 we
still played chess over the board
this is the position magnus has a queen
very nicely placed here uh
sorry 11 has a queen on c8 magnus has a
queen all the way here uh 11's king is
on h2 so it's a pretty crazy position
uh the engine uh after a long crunching
of the position the the engine gives a
four like and the game continues uh
so it's uh it's a pretty pretty crazy
position like
you can't promote the pawn uh since uh
the bishop and the queen are covering
that and you could play a lot of moves
here and it doesn't it doesn't even
matter which is the correct move here
because 11 played queen to b7 check
sorry about that and
uh he just placed his queen here so uh
uh magnus can capture it magnus captured
the queen and his game over 11 resigned
now if such a move happened or uh in an
online game
we'd be like oh come on that's an
obvious mouse slip i mean he obviously
uh wanted to play queen to let's say
queen to a8 check and he accidentally
dropped his queen on b7 and of course i
mean
uh we should rectify this somehow i mean
magnus shouldn't win a game here because
it was an
obvious mouse slip but the thing is it
wasn't an online game it was a game over
the board and levin actually played that
move
and i mean this is not uh an isolated
case there are a lot of cases in chess
but
this is a game that pretty much everyone
knows between two
such elite players like levin and magnus
and uh
11 picked up the queen he placed it in
front of the knight and magnus captured
it some
something you know happens in the brain
and uh you know you you miss
such a simple idea uh it was a rapid
game so of course
both players were very low on time but
uh
i mean games like this uh are a reason
why
we can never know if a mouse slip was
obvious okay kasparov played the
uh queen to d3 instead of queen to c2 in
that game against caruana
and of course everyone said yeah that's
an obvious that's an obvious mistake
sorry about that
uh sorry about that unbelievable the
mailman again and it's actually
uh it's actually for me it's actually
from uh from a subscriber
uh so that's that's very cool uh
not showing any uh you know information
so don't worry about that
it's only uh the uh my work address so
that's
public knowledge anyways uh but yeah
sorry about that but yeah getting back
to this
uh i mean it should uh there's no way
for us to know if uh
if a mouse slip is obvious and uh
therefore uh we have to accept
mouse slips for what they are they are a
part of the game and they are
a part of online chess some of you
mentioned that maybe uh maybe we should
have an actual board connected uh
to yeah to the internet where players
will play against each other
while moving the pieces and then uh you
know such things wouldn't happen
uh but in the heat of battle i mean if
you're down uh with less than a minute
on the clock 30 seconds on the clock
you're gonna have to move the pieces
very fast hit the clock very fast or
maybe
okay maybe it will be without the clock
maybe the clock will uh
pop instantaneously when you hit the uh
hit the board
uh but then again you might you know in
the heat of battle you might
place your queen on on b7 but you
actually wanted to place it on a8 but
you know
you kind of wanted to play it fast and
then the board will register the move
you didn't want to play
so what's that is that like a hand slip
i mean
uh so it's uh it's what it is we're
gonna have to accept it for what it is
and the like like i said unless we're
gonna have some sort of a neural
interface where we'll
where the board will actually know what
move you want to play
there will be no such thing as as an
obvious mouse slip so i i did
give this some consideration and i i
personally didn't uh
figure out any possible way to uh
to like uh uh avoided this
i mean some of you said okay maybe we
could like player plays a move and then
he gets like a pop-up where he wants to
confirm move but in online chess you you
cannot play like this because if you're
especially if it's like an armageddon
game with no um uh with no increment
uh i mean yeah you're gonna lose like a
flagging will be
flat flagging will be uh the main
objective on how you're gonna win games
it's not
not a way to fix this so i don't know if
any of you guys have some sort of a
brilliant idea on how we are we can
maybe eliminate mouse slips uh
you know feel free to share i i would
very much enjoy hearing about them
uh but i just i just don't think that
there is and
game games like this prove it as this is
an over the board game
and i mean this is obviously not another
mouse slip
so uh just something i wanted to share
with you guys i'm very interested in
what do you think of this
uh and you know does it have some merit
uh and yeah that that's it for this
video
uh so yeah uh i would like to thank
gishan bernard
uh mohammed mohammed hassani shy gross
and michael bartlett for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh the next tournament uh
from the saint louis chess club checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if you haven't seen this game to check
it out it's the first link in the
description below
see you soon